everyone has a choice
and every choice has a consequence
[Music]
we didn't defeat The Dark One
we set him free
no one should have that much power
[Music]
together we Face The Impossible
but now in our separate corners of the
world
guiding him that is the only thing that
matters you can't control it
you know you have something inside
something that calls for blood I want to
know
how to control them
the last battle's coming
the whole world will be ours
[Music]
if our friends are in trouble why would
I ever stay here you have no conception
of the power they use you can't do this
by yourself
there are many paths to walk through
tonight
it's not always the most powerful who
write history
it's the ones who survive
I'm tired of being a spoke in the wheel
you're not a Spoke boy you are the water
that turned the wheel itself
[Music]
you ever get tired of being at the
bottom of the top
standing in our way just the biggest
connects in Chicago
foreign Chicago is a violent city you
feel me
right now we just let them fight each
other while we expand our territory
and then when nobody's looking
we slide right on in
watch a grip Widow
we seize this moment it'll get us closer
to becoming the connect
[Music]
is a lunch pin to Bringing Down all of
these gangs
I want eyes on him
we can't keep going to war
what the hell we gonna do now
we're gonna build a train so big
it can't be stopped
let me go he's dangerous
we got enemies iron us cops clocking us
let's face the music to surviving
[Music]
over
hi Mom take her away it's shock therapy
party time give her the juice
are you okay no I'm very irritated
[Music]
I just want to kill my mom and get on
with my life is it too much to ask Let
The Killing Spree begin my mother's not
just evil she's a real [__] hello
schmoes your queen is home we need a b
to unlock dark magic it doesn't say
which being only you can unleash the end
of the world
magic makes you crazy because it falls
in the wrong hands who knows what
unspeakable Horrors can happen your
powers are strong but they are unfocused
come on baby don't miss
me you missed control your emotions
control the magic
impressive you're not the [__] tooth
pumpkin we all thought you were Bean
what do you want is this an
inappropriate
I love you yeah oh so romantic
there will come a time when you must
choose who you would live for and for
whom you would die I've been waiting my
whole life for this one now go the odds
are stacked against us too many people
are gonna die see while in hell I will
be the one with the Pitchfork jabbing
your bum bum oh
[Music]
it's time to bring out the big guns
let's burn this place down down
it's too scary we could go underwater
all right Dad sit down don't tell me
what to do
ladies and gentlemen get ready for
excited I'm soft a big fan of your work
we'll grab dinner tonight all right oh
perfect what time I don't text me okay I
I can't I'll invent it
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
wow
[Music]
at the edge of the universe
Starfleet intercepted a distress call
command things could be related to the
recent attacks
the brink of Destruction the attacks
have all been non-federation ships but
now someone's targeting Starfleet
they're sending us Cerritos I guess
we're finally getting some respect oh oh
man I have to start with Holodeck waste
removal your odor will be repulsive
These Are the Voyages of the crew of the
Starship Cerritos we're all such a good
team we finish each other biofantine
equations
don't get too used to this kind of work
promotions are coming up and I think
you'll be very happy wait really as long
as nothing goes sideways today
all good yeah I love it actually all
part of the Ambiance on September 7th
[Music]
they will have one chance we'll be
friends no matter what our breaks are
that's an order yes ma'am to prove that
they can be more we've worked together
for years I trust you then simply
Slow Down slow down
foreign
dude this is nothing compared to you
know that Pike thing we aren't supposed
to talk about
a new season of Star Trek lower decks
oh man am I in the game Move Along Home
Alabama
[Music]
the reason I said no to you when you
first asked me out do you want to go to
dinner dinner with me and the six times
after that no no no no is because I'm
moving to Brazil
thing
when I got there there was a lake there
a lagoon
they told me not to go but
I didn't listen
[Music]
she told me I had three wishes
when it falls off my wrist
those three wishes will come true
[Laughter]
[Music]
demo
with me
[Music]
all three of your wishes will come true
don't know why
would you even know
[Music]
if you crossed into a fairy tale
a storm is coming there are portals in
this world
that we may never know we've trespassed
through
everywhere
[Music]
I need to know where my wife is
people don't just disappear
s
[Music]
you don't see
but you will
foreign
[Music]
Dixon I come from a place called The
Commonwealth it's in America
[Music]
did you come to be in France
how'd you end up here A bunch of good
decisions
we've been waiting for you
you're the messenger to deliver
America
I know you can get in there safely
[Music]
he's ready for what
to lead the Revival of humanity
[Music]
things happen
things are changing you know maybe
Rosa's staying that way
broken until the world ended
[Music]
if I don't make it back
I wanted to know I tried
[Music]
oh I'm still trying
look we're looking at the documentary
right there our documentary Rob and I
came together to purchase a football
club everything is going exactly the way
we want it to go and then we lost in the
semifinal this was not in the Hollywood
screen
but now millions of people are following
and watching she didn't have before a
lot of a lot of expectation oh my God
the expectation
dear God welcome to rexim we have a new
season on the horizon
[Music]
the
community's growing in a way that is
authentic and real
and Powerful
[Applause]
so the king of England called
[Music]
wow
but if we do not get promoted this year
the club is completely and wholly
unsustainable the burden isn't just
winning and getting out of this league
it's never letting down this community
this season for me it's more than
football
is belief
bring it on
[Music]
as a club
as a town
are The Underdogs we gave ourselves a
mountain to climb Mr Freeman I've got
now it's magic
I look at wrexham as the most special
gift I've ever had in my life
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
I wanted to make a difference
I'm all over this network I need to have
a say in the future of this place what
you are asking is unprecedented
[Music]
you want that seat at the grown-up table
but it's not your turn Alex don't forget
to shut the door on your way out
three two one
we're off to air what's happening
someone's in the system get that
uba has been the target of a Cyber
attack this hack is nuclear certain
things may come to light
did you ever tell anybody
personal things that were never meant to
be shared
let Secrets come out they did not
protect me they didn't protect you
but I did
we are flirting with financial disaster
we need someone with more money than God
I am offering you a Lifeline take the
money
how well do you know this guy what does
that mean do you know how much is at
stake here
chance to create something better but
you have to really really
it's refreshing to get stabbed in the
stomach instead of the back so thanks
[Music]
he's making moves seems like everybody
is
what do you think Stalin I'm gonna run
this place
I know I made a huge mistake but I am
handling it fix it or I will you broke
every rule how do you sit in that chair
every night
thank you
it's time to smash and shatter let's
burn it all down
we should finish what we started
[Music]
bro
the world
[Music]
Wagner books hello yes will you get me
another coffee will you get Advil for me
lla is someone you have to meet
this is Hazel May McCall my new
assistant
really hi
it's just really nice
that you're here right back at you
you know that Hall of white people they
have here
welcome to Wagner
Wagner's just
you'll see
I am ready to recommend your promotion
to assistant editor I'll let so many
incention candles for this
what
foreign
something really strange happened
I told you that company was a hell hole
I feel sorry for anyone who was
unfortunate enough to be in our way
did you come to my apartment last night
what are you talking about
yeah Hazel
girl I told you
have you noticed vanilla acting weird
lately she just seemed a bit off
this has been driving me crazy crazy
crazy crazy
[Music]
I know that this sounds like a
conspiracy theory yeah but every
conspiracy about white people being
whack into being true in like 20 years
I don't like your little games
[Music]
you made me do look what you just made
me do I don't trust nobody and nobody
trusts me I'll be the actress
trust each other right
please
oh
because she's dead
foreign
[Music]
my baby cry
everyone I'm Otis Milburn I'm new here
I'm with the whole model of secondary
team
thank you I just wanted to let you know
a little bit about myself I spend a lot
of my free time thinking about sex
[Music]
and brief sex all day
every day
thinking about sex comes very naturally
because I learned everything I know
about sex from my mum
I'm the cause of everybody's concern be
making them heads turn like
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're brave just sharing wait no
please no don't I'm not in a sexual
relationship with my mother
you're a sex therapist
I am
[Music]
as soon doesn't make a man
that's what's inside the suit that
counts
it's resourcefulness
and perhaps an open heart
well what are you waiting for
I haven't finished my drink
this sacred institution wields power
beyond your imagination
Winston your brother stole something
from me
what he took is very important to a lot
of very dangerous people
find him because if you don't I'll bring
the weight of this whole institution
down on you both
Sharon show our guests the door
we made a big mistake coming here you're
my brother Frankie we have to strike
first
and I need all the help I can get how
are we supposed to believe a guy in an
ascot can pull this off
it's a cravat
[Music]
we're going to take on the Continental
every freak in that hotel will be after
lovely
we need guns
lots of guns
this is more than Vengeance this is
Justice
[Music]
can you dig it
let's take this house
and everything that comes with it
way we go
[Music]
little boy Belmont
your mama took someone from me I loved
I could kill you too
and I will when
[Music]
Victor Belmont
I know how much pain is in your soul
how much sadness
this so-called Revolution it's an
Abomination
but the days of this Abomination will
soon be over
foreign
before
[Music]
I pray for you Victor Belmont
being a hero is not about Glory
it's about sacrifice
welcome to Good olken University hey
we've trained the best and brightest
young Heroes since 1965.
is a safe space for you to thrive
foreign
you could be the first top ranked
freshman in history I think you meant to
say first black woman in seven
but you have a Target on your back
and a few of us are going off campus
let's have a good time
[Music]
I'm still drunk from last night perfect
just take a sip say turbo Rush cures
hangovers I wouldn't pour this on my
giving cured cancer
there are dangerous evil people at that
school
[Music]
everything is
I exploded his tag team explosion
foreign
class is savages here